well good afternoon good afternoon
McGrady my name is Giuseppe pi Yuka yeah
also sometimes it's misspelled as guizi
I can live with that don't worry I work
here in shell something like 400 500
meters from here at the Technology
Center we have here in Amsterdam so
basically I'm at work also during the
weekend yay but okay
you will find teaser presentation with
also the data and the code behind the
presentation my github that was
basically a bright idea to hide my code
that is keypad but if you really really
want you can have a look on my terrible
good by the way I'm a chemical engineer
and engineer I not a data scientist and
I'm not a software called software
developer or bla bla bla
so please please have mercy
okay so why I'm here if you have the
same question it's a problem but okay
I'm here because the oil and gas
industry maybe you don't know but the
youngest industry deals with a big chunk
of data a lot of data and this data
comes from sensors maybe mainly from
pressure sensors from temperature
sensors flow meters and these kind of
things so this means that also what data
normally is full of errors mistakes
outliers weird stuff and of course this
is kind of a complication so I'm
basically I would like to share with you
our workflow how we do our big day job
and in particularly how this means in
terms of Python and at the same time I
would like to share with you our
problems mainly in the sense that you
are two bright people you know the
solution so we have the problems so
maybe we can discuss about that after
the presentation now a bit of
introduction this is the field the
layout of course is just a scheme it's
not the real actual field layout of
appomattox project we are doing in the
Gulf of Mexico so this does not exist
and yet will exist in a couple of years
my job is to connect this tiny yellow
team that are almost not visible but
these things that are well heads I
connect with these well heads in my
model till the production facility that
is the big thing on the top left and I
do physical modeling of these networks
if the network exists it's basically it
means that their problems and they want
to
answers if the debt work does not exist
basically I have to compare different
concepts in order to understand if there
are problems and which concept is the
best so basically I will talk a lot of
pipelines and networks but yeah the
old-fashioned concept of pipelines steel
pipelines now just a few words about the
boundary conditions of these physical
models at the outlet of the system so
basically where the big thing lies Wow
incredible basically here I have the
basically the pressure the receiving
pressure of my facilities while here at
the inlet of my model I have the
temperature and the flow this is another
tiny little beast
it's called the prelude also this one
does not exist yet will be in production
next year probably yeah this will be the
biggest floating vessel all around the
world 500 meters and all these pipe
small pipings that are almost invisible
here will have a pressure a temperature
a flow meter and a lot of other kind of
meters so you can only maybe imagine the
amount of data that this this will
generate per second well only draw so
far this is an existing this is the GU
most platform in Malaysia and just to
give you an order of magnitude is a
window so it is a big a big thing this
is the the holodeck here we have the
flare and that's where the production is
collected processor and exported
normally and inside this platform and in
all our production facilities you have
these kind of rooms in the control room
where you have operators that's the
control room of the same platform these
operators have to take decision
based on what they see on these screens
basically they have a simplified version
of the control system of the platform
and they have to operate the platform in
order to avoid incidents and so on one
thing that I didn't mention so far is
the fact that in our pipelines we have
moved phase flow so we have gas and
liquids liquids because mainly often we
have more than one liquid phase and yeah
you may have this nice thing happening
so basically a bulk of liquid a big wave
of liquids that travels to your system
it's called a disliking and it's our
nightmare basically this can happen also
when your boundary conditions are stable
so even if your inlet conditions and
outlet conditions are completely stable
yeah you may have this thing and this is
quite dangerous because it can damage
your production facilities and also your
pipelines
if you feel if you think that I'm
talking something that is completely
well if you want feel free to ask me to
stop and ask something
now I will share with you four examples
one is about two input and output data
check the second one is a completely
theoretical design case of a sizing
exercise and the third and one and
fourth ones are about two fields one in
Iraq and another one in UK so let's
start with the input output we live in a
world of interfaces that's where the
devil is basically I get a lot of data
from other departments and from other
companies and I have to run my models
and I have to share with the other so
via the departments and other companies
the outcomes of this study so it's very
very important at the beginning of a
project a beginning of a study to
understand what you receive
to do a check on what you have and in
order to do that I brought my own
library yeah it's called PFS also this
one is on github and yeah if you really
have nothing better to do and there are
a lot of other things you can do nicely
we have a nice weather but if you really
want you can have a look also about this
library that's the kind of data I me
received at the beginning of a project
basically here we have the liquid
density and the pressure and the
temperature it's a 3d plot and these are
the actual values of the liquid density
now my question to you is is this a good
fluid model or a bad food model yeah you
know the answer is it depends in the
sense that here we have a big step
between this area and this other area
but this one happens at very low turn
well but recently low temperatures so
this may be something that is realistic
because at low temperatures you have
phase changes in your system and yeah
maybe it's also not so relevant for us
these steps here are a bit more scaring
for me because they happen in a region
of pressure and temperature that it's
maybe where my pipeline operates so yeah
this one it's not a great model and it's
not a great model not for this step but
for these steps so you may if you
receive something like that you may
reconsider to rebuild rebuilt your fluid
model yeah this one is certain is an
example about the outcomes of a model
so basically it is a pressure profile of
a pipeline here and this is the maximum
pressure that the pipeline can sustain
and yeah basically the answer I got this
time was if I have a problem and here at
the outlet of the system and I keep
injecting mass at the inlet of the
system after how many seconds or minutes
or hours or days
I'll have problems so basically we can
run we can move in time the pressure
yeah yeah after something like 1800
seconds yeah we will have a problem at
to the inlet of the pipeline it's fancy
well in the world I live this is very
fancy so you should say oh great at
least for management works yeah but is
it is very cool this is completely done
in in Python because likely the outcome
of my models are playing text file so
it's very easy to person to process this
information now
let's go to a simple pipeline sizing
exercise this is simple in in the sense
that is unrealistic the reality is much
more complicated unfortunately but let's
assume you are requested to size a
pipeline sizing the pipeline means that
you have to define mainly not only but
mainly the pipeline diameter and the
thermal insulation of your of your
pipeline they say you have to go from
point A to point B in the simplest case
where you have a single pipeline you of
course you may have networks and you
have to come out with these two values
easy first of all of course let's check
what we get do you think we have a
problem this is an elevation profile so
basically my Wells my Inlet my Inlet
mass flow is here and I have to deliver
my production here and the pipeline will
go up and down following the slope of
the terrain yes we have a problem we
have a problem in sense that yeah if
this is if these were the real pipeline
well this is about the size of the earth
diameter they did a mistake in the unit
of measure this happened to me
really and this one was easy to spot but
in other cases it's much more
complicated anyway it's time to simulate
now we have several flow rates we wanna
we wanna transport through our pipeline
we have an idea about the pipeline
diameter we wanna we wanna have and we
have a best-case scenario now the most
important outcome of the analysis would
be the real pipeline diameter we want to
have so we want to be sure that we did
the diameter the bigger or the lower
diameter
are performing not at the same level
respect to our base case so yeah of
course there's a type of sorry about
that but basically we wanna have
different diameters maybe we have a
winter and summer maybe we have
different ISIL installations and we have
a bit of uncertainty about what we what
what is the fluid temperature and the
water mass rate so in DC it is very very
easy scenario we have almost 800 cases
to simulate now I have collects that if
they have to do this job they manually
change almost 800 input files it's a bit
set but that's how it is but yeah for
with Python it's very very easy we can
use either tools and the product
function if you don't know either tools
check out this library it's awesome it's
great yeah and we here we can very
easily create our 800 cases and yeah
it's simply a matter of processing the
text if you want to generate your 800
input files okay now we have simulated
our cases let's see what we get that's
the most important outcome so the inlet
pressure of the pipeline as I said at
the beginning we the outlet pressure is
constant and we want to understand what
is the impact at the inlet so of course
the the inlet pressure goes up with the
the flow rate this continues green line
is our base case scenario and the other
two are exactly the same basic a
Shannara but we did the other diameters
18 and 28 18 and 60 sorry 16 and 20
inches as you would expect if you
increase the flow rate the inlet
pressure goes up but for a multi-phase
pipeline this is quite uncommon for well
not easy to understand if you are not of
part of the business but at low flow if
you increase the flow rate your pressure
drop goes down
this is an effect of the balance between
friction and gravity gravity pressure
drop of the pipeline but ok so this plot
is important because basically you
understand the maximum pressure you may
experience in your your lifetime and the
blue dots are all the other all the
other combinations the same for the
temperature the absolute temperature is
also another very important parameter
because if the temperature well
temperature goes down you have problems
solids problem the position basically
and we see that in this case the
diameter is not affecting so much the
outlet temperature there's not a lot of
variance between these cases so there
are other factors that are that are
important but it's not the diameter
another very important parameter another
result of our models is the liquid
content yeah if you increase the flow
rate you have less liquid stored in your
pipeline that's easy to imagine but yeah
you see that on this side it is these
are cubes cubic meters yeah you may have
pretty big amount chunk of liquid
storage in your pipeline and of course
you have to deal with with this liquid
when you do stuff like increasing the
production or other transients now let's
have a look on and a real case this is
not the case I will show you but yeah
that's the kind of thing that may happen
at your pipeline if it's lagging
so as longing pipeline it's a bad thing
bad bad thing and that's why I have a
job and basically the first thing you
have to do when you are studying a
pipeline that is doing this nasty job is
to understand what is the frequency of
this phenomena because it's a natural
phenomena with a nice frequency usually
so I got from this Araki yogini pipeline
that you datasets each one of few days
of production a lot of pressure tangent
and useless stuff and actually without a
unit of
but okay we managed to solve that and
one important thing is the fact that one
important thing is the fact that the
sampling frequency was 86 second
remember this number now let's have a
look on what we got that's the first
it's not exactly a week it's five days
of production but okay working week you
see that yeah this is the liquid outflow
from the pipeline that it means it's the
liquid that is arriving at the outlet of
my model in this case this is an
existing pattern so these are real this
is real data it's not simulated data
well it's a mess a lot of things are
happening you see that here we have
periods of time where with no production
that means that the system was down and
we have periods of time where the
production is increasing because
probably they are ramping up the
production yeah so what we can do with
this data basically we can try to cut a
portion of the data that are meaningful
for us because we won't understand the
frequency of ours liking is lagging when
nothing else or almost nothing else is
happening and that's the same also for
second product the second week was in
this case we can define two blocks of
data that are relatively good let's have
a look on them
so for each block I have extracted cut
the signal and I have averaging to zero
in order to do an FFT an FFT
transformation on on the data no it's
not so bad but it's also not so nice
let's have a look on the other ones yeah
it is one it's slightly better
finally the
third block and the last one now yeah
this one it's nice I like it because
there's quite there's probably something
else that is happening not a lot of
other things probably who knows if I
calculate the number of minutes the time
interval between one's luck add another
one I got this using simply the highest
peak I get these numbers and these are
means that basically in these four
different block periods production
period the the time between one slag and
another one ranges from six point five
to ten minutes this is a great result
because considering the amount of things
that that are really happening in the
field yeah this variation it's not so
big one question for you do you think
that the same thing frequency frequency
was enough or not yeah that's the answer
I was waiting for yeah the the frequency
was was good enough because it was 86
seconds basically we have four or five
points per slot so it's enough to
capture a phenomena in the order of
magnitude of a few minutes the last
example is about a gas condensate
network in here in the North Sea okay
basically there are a lot of platforms
production platforms where there are
some wells in total in this case nine
production wells that this production is
collected through this big platform here
and after its transferred to onshore now
basically if you look here the size of
these pipelines these are few kilometers
this means this is a problem it's a
problem because it means that in my
physical model I cannot simulate with
the fancy 3d CFD stuff these kind of
things otherwise I can stay here till my
next job I have to simplify the model in
mono dimensional simulations and another
nasty thing is the fact that most of the
most of the information I have is at the
inlet I have pressure and temperatures
at the inlet of these platforms and I
have the liquid flow rate here on shore
now basically the the issues that I
tried to correlate things that are
happening hours before to what I see
here so there's a time shift between the
inlet and the outlet and this time shift
is also time dependent in the sense that
it depends on the flow rate we have in
this system so this system believe me it
was a nightmare to model it was a
nightmare because you need to start from
a city state point of production and it
was almost impossible here because the
boundary conditions were changing there
harvly
and also you don't we don't have
information about to the liquid that is
produced per well and in terms of
liquids the information was available
available only on shore but we managed
to do something we managed to run the
model linking the model with the
production database basically the model
itself has a nice function that is able
to retrieve information from the
production database and uses this
information partially to to feed the
model and partially to compare
predictions and
actual measurements why this is
important it's important because in that
in that way of work I don't mind about
the starting point of my model I simply
follow the history and I can also replay
replay the production history doing some
tuning and these are the outcomes so
these are two very important parameters
in this case basically deep like all in
the salt concentration at the mass
fraction at the outlet of the of the
model and of the system of course you
see that these are half a year and you
know there's a decent agreement not
excellent but decent this is these are
the residuals and you see that the
average in both cases it's zero this is
a very nice thing because it means that
our tuning was successful and at same
time you see here that the probability
distribution of these of these two
residuals is kind of not exactly but
kind of normal now is this good enough
yes this was very it was a great
achievement it's basically as far as I
know you cannot do better with a
physical model a physical modelling in
this case I cannot I cannot do better
but at the same time yeah we had to do
some compromises in order to have
basically a decent computational speed
and also sometimes the model it's not
accurate as we would like so is there
anything we can do well this is more a
question for you in the sense that maybe
we can implement some machine learning
algorithm in order to do the tuning
because as I said before we had to do
this tuning about the liquid inflow and
this was done manual it was a long and
boring process maybe we can use also an
efficient neural network or a machine
the algorithm in order to generate a
visual metering system there are
Victoire metering systems out of there
but they are very simply curve 15 curve
fitting algorithms and I think we can do
much better than this and yeah maybe we
have also physical model we can create
as a terrible hybrid between these
physical model and a machine learning
algorithm or or a network I don't know I
have no idea if this is feasible or not
so conclusions yeah it's obvious to you
but it's not obvious out of this room
that Python is or other programming
languages are very helpful if you have
to process and every process your data
input and output and yeah one other
thing that is not so clear outside this
room is the fact that nowadays we have a
lot of cases to simulate and even for
basic and absolutely not realistic cases
you have hundreds of simulations to do
and of course you have to manage the
outcomes of these simulations and in the
end this is very important for me as oil
and gas industry we have a very long and
robust traditions of physical modeling
you cannot imagine how sophisticated how
complex our models for reservoirs for
course that are big 3d beasts we do
really cool stuff with physical modeling
but instead the other things that are
not physical modeling are not so common
there are some small examples but
believe me that there aren't significant
applications and we have also a lot of
data really we have a lot of data a lot
of data data has to be clean as big
processes and so on but we have a lot of
things and yeah we barely use this
information that's maybe where you can
help
as you really want if you really want as
I said there are a lot of better things
to do but yeah you'll find on my github
but is told with all the data and also
my library I had to add this sorry they
were complaining about fact that I was
not using the standard way to present
because of course yeah you have not said
that I'm not the only one with the
PowerPoint presentation here so yeah I
had to give them at least this please
get the hand of applause for proper
execution of the image functionality in
the ipython not only was I done applause
for the talk but also for the proper use
of the image functionality in the
ipython notebook this I personally found
this a very interesting topic are there
any questions about the applications of
Python maybe for oil and gas companies
or companies maybe where there's more of
a physical modeling type of structure
yeah thank you very talk I have a
question though about the application
because well I'm wondering are using
right now modeling and physical modeling
and these techniques mainly for design
purposes or is it for maintenance or
identifying security risks well in this
case in the last example teaser net news
network is existing hmm so basically we
were asked to predict the liquid outflow
here when they do something some things
here as I said before there's quite some
distance so if you for example increase
the production from one of these wells
you will see the outcome in terms of
liquid the hair after a few days and
this was very important because of
course you need to be prepared in order
to process the liquids that are coming
so we normally do our modeling for
existing and non existing pipelines for
existing pipelines normal
we have to solve problems for non
existing pipelines we have to compare
different concepts how to link different
how to compare different networks
because yeah this is existing but of
course you if you have only the yellow
boxes here you may also have the idea
how I can connect these boxes in order
to deliver my production I have I
answered to your question not really and
and one more thing then when it comes to
maintenance and using data you mentioned
yourself garbage in garbage out well a
lot of physical or mechanical engineers
they're very skeptical about use of data
at least when I was in business it's
it's true we have a problem with with
data quality absolutely
I wonder if if there's someone that
doesn't have this problem but okay
basically all the times we have a
repository relative to a single specific
project and what you have in that
repository should be the truth is this
the case not really
not always and so basically the step in
which you have to gather your data and
to check your data to do a sanity check
on your data it sometimes it's very very
time-consuming yeah we can do much
better than that yes I see Oh two more
questions
oh boy thank you for the talk my
question about the period of data uses
elected how you come up to the decision
in practice about those block size how
you get a concise with domain expert or
data sciences that is the data we gonna
analyze I think it was five days of data
yes am I correct yeah in one case five
and the other case for enough to make a
conclusion with this short period of
that because one of your parameters was
temperature and in this case it was not
a problem because
Iraq is not very famous for difference
between winter and summer but yes
definitely in other cases when we have
big changes in terms of ambient
temperature you need to be ready to use
data from different time periods in this
case it was good enough and also the
idea was a slightly different sense that
we have a problem we have a problem now
tell us what is happening so you we were
interested in the few weeks before the
now not in the world full history of the
pipeline but yeah normally you should
evaluate both then we've got another
question over here thank you for the
talk and I'd like to ask how big is
actually data science in oil or chemical
industry as I said I think it's very
it's there aren't that there's no expect
is almost no expertise but at the same
time we have a lot of opportunities my
opinion we have the data and also I I
think that we are very open to
innovation particularly nowadays so the
as far as I know there are examples of
real applications only in the subsurface
world so when you model reservoirs there
you have some machine learning
relatively well established techniques
another thing that it's completely not
mentioned in my presentation is the
drilling so it's quite complicated to
understand where you should drill your
next well and also for these kind of
things there are some artificial Network
neural networks techniques that are used
at the but yeah basically the answer is
there isn't a lot of experience in that
in particularly in the upstream another
question
my question is also about how there
might be legal regulations in this area
I mean do you envision government being
happy to know that maybe you were making
decisions purely on a machine learning
model rather than a physical model well
I don't think this is a much of a
problem but not because but not because
we have tried maybe this will be a real
problem I don't know but you have to
consider also that our physical models
are not perfect so it's not a matter of
comparing the truth with something fancy
nice nerdy that is without no sense and
that's also why I think that video
metering can be can be something
relatively easy to to use and to
implement in the sense that you at the
beginning you will have a physical model
running in parallel with your Vista
metering system and so it's very easy to
compare the performance test of the two
and it's very easy to convince someone
else that you are doing a good job but
there's no answer yet
then I suppose I have the courtesy of
having the final question so I imagine
you know because you're mostly working
with say physicists I'm assuming and
people with strong technical background
and there is also the phenomenon that I
always experience if you get a group of
people that are very technical and then
you say hey there's this new toy we can
teach ourselves that there's generally
quite a lot of excitement even if you're
used to physical models and how is the
attitude sort of for the engineers
because it seems like it might be very
keen to learn new things and it's very
exciting but at the same time these are
usually physicists so they would like
two things to work in the physical world
as well there's a famous motto in the
oil and gas industry that we really
wanna be the second one who apply a
technology not the first one and why
because we like the innovation we like
new things new stuff we are very prone
to that but that's entirely if something
goes wrong is one of this pipeline is
leaking is one of this pipeline is
leaking in the North Sea you can easily
imagine that it's not exactly a good
time for us so that's why yeah normally
it's very complicated it's fairly easy
to start to begin with a new technology
it's very very complicated to deploy
this technology throughout our our
assets all all around the world the
Python seems to be getting towards an
accepted state if we say yes absolutely
yeah I'm here to represent that awesome
good to hear
everyone please give a warm applause to
our speakers